la parole est à Monsieur Philippe
daliier pour le groupe
um merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Premier ministre lors de CVO
français le président de la République a
donné le sentiment de vouloir infléchir
la politique économique et budgétaire du
gouvernement cet infléchissement du
discours en tous les cas partait d'un
constat la croissance n'a pas été au
rendez-vous de l'année 2013 François
Hollande a d'ailleurs une nouvelle fois
reconnue avoir sous-estimé la gravité de
la crise donnant à ses vœ un air de
méaculpa car s'il faut un
infléchissement c'est bien que la
politique conduite n'était pas la bonne
le président semble enfin admettre qu'il
y a toujours un grave problème de
compétitivité de nos entreprises
pourtant le Crédit Impôt compétitivité
emploi instrument phare de la boîte à
outils présidentiel était censé y
remédier mais voilà le bilan est là en
2013 la marge de nos entreprises a été
historiquement la plus faible pourquoi
et bien c'est malheureusement très
simple les impôts et les charges pesants
sur les entreprises ont augmenté de 16
milliards de depuis l'été 2012 alors que
le cice n'a encore produit que peu
d'effets et de toute manière même en
année pleine il compensera à peine ses
hausses en quelque sorte vous avez déjà
repris d'une main ce que vous n'aviez
pas encore donné de l'autre le président
de la République ne pouvait pas mieux
démontrer que le gouvernement a eu bien
tort de supprimer le dispositif de TVA
social que nous avions adopté et qui
aurait pu entrer en vigueur le 1er
octobre 2012 vous avez perdu 18 mois et
ces 18 mois se sont soldés par des milli
de chômeurs faut-il rappeler que 13000
PME ont mis la clé la porte sous la
porte l'année dernière voilà un autre
record vieux de 20 ans que vous avez
battu François Hollande nous a donc
annoncé que le gouvernement travaillait
à un Pact de responsabilité et de
compétitivité bonne nouvelle car mieux
vaut tard que jamais mais monsieur le
Premier ministre le Parlement vient de
voter le budget de l'État et celui de la
sécurité sociale nous n'y avons rien vu
qui ressemble à cela le président de la
République a laissé entendre que ce
pacte serait financé par des réductions
de dépenses supplémentaires encore
faudrait-il que de véritables réformes
structurelles soient engagées et que
vous cessiez tous les 3 mois d'annoncer
de nouvelles dépenses alors monsieur le
Premier ministre le changement est-ce
maintenant le discours des vux
présidentiels estil vraiment le signe
d'une inflexion sociale libérale si
c'est bien le cas quels sont les actes
de ce pacte de responsabilité avec nos
entreprises et surtout comment le
financerez-vous merci monsieur le
Premier ministre vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieurs le
sénateurs je suis toujours étonné
d'entendre aussi bien au Sénat qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale les représentants
de l'UMP faire la leçon au
gouvernement fireme la leçon au
gouvernement sans être capable une seule
fois sans être capable une seule fois de
faire la moindre proposition
si je je reconnais que le président de
votre parti monsieur Copé a fait une
proposition de baisse de la dépense
publique de 130 milliards mais sans
jamais une fois dire de quelle dépense
il s'agit vous êtes bien gardé de le
faire parce que vous en avez vous avez
fait la démonstration lorsque vous étiez
au pouvoir de faire exactement le
contraire pour ça que je vous le
rappelle parce que la situation dans
laquelle nous sommes que dans ma
déclaration de politique générale de
juillet 2012 où j'avais décrit la
situation du pays et je vous y renvoie
j'avais déjà décrit cette situation mais
en 5 ans de présidence Sarko vous avez
augmenté la dépense publique de 4 points
de la richesse nationale 4at points de
PIB c'est pas nous c'est vous nous avons
hérité d'une situation où le la dette
avait augmenté de 600 milliards le
déficit si nous n'avions rien fait était
à 6 % et là nous n'avons pas cesser
depuis que j'exerce la responsabilité de
chef du gouvernement de mettre en œuvre
un programme de redressement de la
situation de notre pays nous ne sommes
pas au terme de ce plan de redressement
monsieur le sénateur mais simplement
quand vous vous faites par exemple au
moment des lois de finances puisque vous
venez d'y faire référence allusion au
vote qui a été celui de la majorité
gouvernementale de cette loi de finance
et de cette loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale je vous demande
simplement d'avoir un tout petit peu de
mémoire et de vous rappeler les
amendements que vous avez proposés au
Sénat vous savez de combien ils
augmentaient la dépense publique 70
milliards d'euros donc je vous rappelle
à un peu plus de dessence un peu plus de
responsabilité alors en ce qui nous
concerne vous vous souvenez bien que
après le rapport Gallois j'avais annoncé
un Pact de compétitivité pour la
croissance et pour l'emploi et vous avez
fait allusion à toute une série de
mesures notamment l'organisation en
filière l'évolution de notre système de
formation professionnelle le soutien au
PME la création d'une banque public
d'investissement et la baisse du coût du
travail et cette baisse du coût du
travail qui je rappelle et certains le
critiquent vous coûte 20 milliards
d'euros au budget de l'État c'est un
effort considérable qui est demandé tous
les Français a pour but de redonner des
marge de manœuvre aux entreprises et
c'est cette année l'année 2014 que ces
mesures vont être effectives il était
possible pour l'année dernière pour les
entreprises qui on faisaiit la demande
d'anticiper le bénéfice de ce crédit
d'impôt grâce aux avances de la trés de
trésorerie de la banque publique
d'investissement mais une petite partie
seulement des entreprises et
particulièrement les PME il ont fait
appel mais aujourd'hui ce sont toutes
les entreprises qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier de ces 4 % de baisse du coût
du travail donc une marge de manœuvre
très importante qui se prolongera
l'année prochaine jusqu'à 6 % et c'est
par cette marge de manœuvre
supplémentaire que nous souhaitons
effectivement redonner aux entreprises
des capacités d'investir des Capac
capacité d'innover les capacités
d'embaucher au moment où les efforts qui
ont été entrepris sont en train de
porter leur fruit en matière de
croissance vous voyez que nous sommes
repartis sur une un rythme de croissance
beaucoup plus élevé que ce que nous
avons connu en 2013 alors que pendant 5
ans en moyenne depuis la crise de 2008-
200009 la croissance a été de 0 % avec
tous les dégâts que ça peut faire sur le
plan des chiffres du chômage sur le plan
des chiffres de l' emploi dans les
régions les entreprises qui ont été
détruites ça c'est la réalité que nous
connaissions dans notre pays et
maintenant nous sommes sur un
redémarrage en France et en Europe et
c'est là qu'il faut consolider et c'est
le sens du pacte que le Président de la
République propose mais il le propose
aux entreprises il le propose aux
partenaires sociaux pour que le
redressement soit au service de l'emploi
la priorité de nos priorités de toutes
les priorités c'est le retour de la
croissance c'est la création d'emploi
c'est ça la B taille centrale dans
laquelle vous pourriez aussi apporter
votre concours et pas simplement par des
propositions démagogiques et l'enjeu est
essentiel pour l'avenir de notre pays
sans pour autant alors que nous ne
sommes pas au bout des difficultés
financière pour réduire la dette parce
que c'est indispensable pour redonner à
notre pays des marges de manœuvre nous
ne sommes pas au bout de ce chantier
mais pour autant nous voulons à tout
prix préserver les fondamentaux de notre
modèle social le président de la public
l'a dit aussi et vous l'avez pas évoqué
dans votre intervention l'enjeu c'est
réformer notre pays le moderniser sans
pour autant défaire ce qui fait sa
cohésion et en particulier sa cohésion
sociale c'est-à-dire notre modèle social
pour ça il faut accepter des réformes et
la France est capable de se réformer et
je voudrais prendre plusieurs exemples
pour montrer que nous sommes capables de
nous réformer alors qu'on dit dans cette
espèce de mauvaise mode à laquelle
parfois vous vous laissez entraîner vous
aussi de de France baching la France
serait pas capable de se réformer mais
enfin qui a été capable de créer les
conditions pour que les partenaires
sociaux trouvent un accord le 11 janvier
2012 pour la réforme du marché du
travail c'est sous cette majorité
ensuite il y a eu la réforme des
retraites et bien rappelez-vous les
autres réformes qui ont toujours donné
lieu à des mouvements sociaux
considérables nous avons après
concertation fait voter par l'Assemblée
nationale en dernière lecture juste
avant Noël cette réforme des retraites
et puis la dernière réforme celle dont
vous allez débattre dans quelques temps
qui est la réforme de la formation
professionnelle un accord entre le
patronat et les syndicats est intervenu
en fin d'année 2013 et qui va vous
permettre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs j'espère que vous serez
largement nombreux à le faire de voter
une nouvelle réforme et toute cette tous
ces réformes y compris celle de la
refondation de l'école qui est essentiel
aussi pour l'avenir de notre pays pour
l'avenir de la jeunesse mais aussi pour
la compétitivité de notre pays sont des
réformes qui portent leurs fruits qui
vont porter leurs fruits et qui vont
permettre à la France de repartir de
l'avant avec puissance avec force avec
confiance tout en gardant sa spécificité
son modèle social qui est aussi le
garant du pacte et de la solidarité
nationale merci la parole